Melania Trump as we all know did not
attend her husband's victory speech
after his indictment and arraignment
last Tuesday
so she didn't show up for that
previous reports before that even
happened said Melania Trump wants
nothing to do with her husband's legal
problems
she's going about living her life she
lives in a separate Wing at Mar-A-Lago
they do not share living quarters so
they're not even sleeping in the same
bed so that's usually a pretty big
indication that there's some marital
problems there and these reports say
that Melania spends most of her days
happy with with Baron and her parents
who also live down there and they're
just going about their lives as if none
of this is even happening
good for her